♪ ♪
[LAUGHS]
>> Jeanine: NOT REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT SEARCHING GAS
PRICES, PRIVATE JET OWNER AND
CLIMATE STAR JOHN KERRY IS
PUSHING CLIMATE ALARMISM.
>> FOSSIL FUEL IS ALLOWED TO
GROW IN A SIGNIFICANT WAY AS IT
APPEARS POISED TO DO.
IT IS A DEEP UNBELIEVABLE COSTLY
CHALLENGE FOR THE WORLD.
>> Jeanine: IS CLIMATE CHANGE
A DEEP CHALLENGE FOR THE WORLD?
>> Dana: IT IS A CHALLENGE, IT
IS.
THERE'S A LOT OF CHALLENGES SO
MANY OF HER TIGHT ABOUT THE
TOTAL DUE LIST THE OTHER DAY.
I THINK HAVING SOMEONE WHO FLIES
AROUND IN A PRIVATE JET SAYING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS IS
MAYBE NOT THE BEST MESSENGER.
I UNDERSTAND THAT AS IT IS A
PROBLEM BUT I ALSO UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU CAN'T CHANGE THE LAWS
OF PHYSICS.
IT'S WONDERFUL TO HAVE
INNOVATION AND ENCOURAGE PEOPLE
TO TRY TO DO THINGS.
IT'S REALLY INTERESTING THINGS
GOING ON WITH FUSION FOR
EXAMPLE.
BUT ARE TAKEN ONE ISSUE AND
THEY'RE GONNA GET ANOTHER ONE.
THE FOSSIL FUELS GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS, PROBLEM THEN IS TO BE
DEALT WITH OKAY.
BUT NOW PUSHING SO QUICKLY TO
HAVE ELECTRIC VEHICLES ALSO
DOING ALL THE SUBSIDIES SO THE
RICH PEOPLE CAN HAVE ELECTRIC
VEHICLES OR TO FOR EXAMPLE.
THE RED THINGS THAT ARE NEEDED
FOR THAT TO HAPPEN ALL THOSE
MINERALS.
OF CLIMATE PROBLEMS AND YOU HAVE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROBLEMS,
POLITICAL PROBLEMS THAT COME
FROM THAT AS WELL.
>> Jeanine: WHY DON'T THEY SEE
THAT STUFF?
ONE OF ANTICIPATE THAT?
>> THAT'S REALLY WHAT IT COMES
DOWN TO COMING WITH ME ON ONE
SIDE OR THE OTHER.
TELL ME ABOUT THE KEYSTONE
PIPELINE WORKERS HAVE LEARNED,
HOW MANY OF THEM HAVE BEEN READ
JOB?
I'M IN THEM OR MAKE A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR MAKING
AN ENERGY JOB THEY'RE STILL
PRETTY PIT STOP HOW THINGS WENT
DOWN WITH THEIR JOB TO TAKE
THEIR LIVELIHOOD AWAY FROM THEM.
YOU CANNOT BE THE PARTY THAT
TOUTS THE PARTY OF THE
DOWNTRODDEN AMERICANS WAS AT A
TERRIBLE GO AT IT BE THE ONES
WHO DOWN TROTTING THEM.
TO BE ONES PULL THE RUG OUT FROM
UNDER THEM.
I'M A CONSERVATIONIST.
BUT THE LINE BETWEEN
ENVIRONMENTALISM AND CLIMATE
CHANGE, THAT'S A BROADER --
THOSE ARE TWO VERY DIFFERENT
THINGS.
THERE'S NO SUBPOENA UNDERSTAND
THE NEEDS TO CONSERVE OUR
RESOURCES, AND TRYING TO SHOVE
IT DOWN OUR THROATS TO THE POINT
WHERE LAKE TRAVIS IS ON TV THIS
MORNING SAYING THAT HE WANTS
SOMEONE TO 1 GALLON OF FUEL IN
THEIR CAR FOR $4.59.
SO THEY COULD AFFORD.
IT WOULD START ABOUT POLK
STEUBEN HOUSE.
NOT ONLY ARE YOU PUSHING VOTERS
TOWARD THE REPUBLICANS.
YOU PUSH THE AMERICANS AWAY FROM
EVEN BELIEVING IN CLIMATE CHANGE
WANTING TO SUPPORT IT.
THAT'S WHAT'S SO IRONIC AND
DUMBFOUNDED ABOUT THIS.
>> Jeanine: WERE THE MOST
AMAZING THINGS THAT WERE NOT
HOLDING BACK ANY DRILLING.
APPARENTLY THE CLIMATE ADVISOR
ALSO SAYS THAT
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN IS COMMITTED
TO OPPOSING ANY ADDITIONAL
DRILLING.
TO THE EVEN KNOW WHAT THEIR
POSITION IS AS IT RELATES TO
DRILLING OTHER THAN THEY ARE
APPEALING TO THE LEFT?
>> WE SHOULD BE DRILLING AND WE
SHOULD BE BUILDING NUCLEAR.
SHOULD BE FRACKING.
REALITIES IS CLIMATE CHANGE IS
REAL.
BUT TO HER POINT WE HAVE TO BE
THOUGHTFUL AND SERIOUS ABOUT HOW
WE MAKE THE TRANSITION.
THE WAR IN UKRAINE OBVIOUSLY
MADE THIS A FAR MORE RELEVANT
AND IMPORTANT CONVERSATION.
FOR THE LIFE OF ME THIS MOMENT
JUST SCREAM FOR SOME SANITY.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE THIS WAY OR
THAT WAY ON THIS.
WE CAN BOTH SAY YOUR
CONSERVATIONIST MORE CLIMATE
CHANGE IN THE REALITIES OF IT TO
ADDRESS WE WANT ELECTRIC CALLS
AND BATTERIES ONE THING IS
TRYING TO BUILD ALL THE
BATTERIES IN TEN YEARS FOR AN
HOUR AND I SO WE CAN JUST
ABANDON IT ALTOGETHER.
>> A LIST FRIEND FRED SMITH SAID
THAT PRESIDENT OBAMA SAW HIM
ONCE I'M DONE MY POLL NUMBERS
CORRELATE DIRECTLY TO OIL
PRICES.
I MAY NOT SEE MUCH MORE.
IF YOU FIND YOURSELF IN A BIND
COME NOVEMBER WE COULD REALLY BE
IN A BIND IF YOU DON'T LOOK AT
IT TRYING TO ADJUST THE ISSUE.
>> Jeanine: I MET SOME GREAT
THAT YOU AGREE THAT CLIMATE
CHANGE IS NOT EXISTENTIAL THREAT
THAT THEY SAY IT IS PUSH MARK
>> Greg: I THINK IT IS A
CHALLENGE THAT WE WILL BE FACING
A LOT OF THESE SOLUTIONS ARE
COMING FROM THE LEFT ARE
UNRELIABLE WITH HER AT SOLAR
PANELS OR WIND MILLS WHEN YOU
LOOK AT CNN PLUS HOW MUCH MONEY
THEY INVESTED IN WIND POWER
WIRING CHRIS WALLACE.
[LAUGHS]
SO ANYWAY WHEN THE DEFENDANT THE
PRESIDENT OR TALK ABOUT THIS I
GUESS JUST FRONT OF THE BILLION
DOLLAR EFFORT TO SAVE DISTRESSED
NUCLEAR POWER PLANTS TO SECURE
OUR ENERGY SUPPLY?
SO THAT IS GREAT THING WHICH I
THINK WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT HAVING
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS THE
MOM OF THE DATA IN THE SAME ROOM
THAT'S WHAT YOU GET.
YOU GET A SOLUTION FOR BOTH CAN
AGREE.
IT NUCLEAR POWER IS ESSENTIALLY
GONNA BE OUR FUTURE, WE JUST
HAVE TO AMEND IT AS A CERTAIN
POINT THERE WERE INFANTS ARE
BUILDING UP ROLLS-ROYCE CAN BE
BUILDING THE SMALLER PLANTS IN A
CLEAN, OR OPEN A LIVE WITH
UNICORNS AND CLOUDS.
>> Jeanine: THAT YOU HAVE IT.
COMING UP AHEAD, MIKE TYSON
PUNCHES OU